good afternoon everybody i hope
everybody's well
um have we any apologies for absence yes
chair we have an apology from councillor
huckabee
okay thank you alan uh do we have any
declarations of interest
uh none have been received chair thank
you uh
right we've got to approve the minutes
of the last two meetings
uh the first one being um the general
licensing
committee held on the 22nd of october
[Music]
have we got anybody move it
all right thank you um and council
eminence seconds it i think thank you
and then we have the minutes held on the
third of december
michelle emmons
thank you right we'll move on to
remembers content sorry just uh yeah
does anybody want to
can we all vote on that sorry
yes members of contention thank you alan
right item four taxi policy updates
now has everybody been able to see this
yep yeah and just to remind to chair
that there was an update to the appendix
which went out that's what everybody's
seen the
the new version yeah yeah
uh right that's my
item okay yes over to you kevin thank
you thank you i would like to start with
apologizing for the error with the
appendix
uh there's multiple versions of this
document drawn up over a period of time
as you can imagine
in my haste to get it to governance i
accidentally it's actually wrong one
so i do apologize for any confusion that
caused
um i don't intend to go into a great
deal of uh detail
about the report that i've submitted um
you'll recall when we brought the cctv
policy forward we explained that there
had been government guidance issued
which prescribes that councils should
unless there's a good local reason
adopt um the practice that's set out in
that guidance
what we've done subsequent to that is go
through the existing policy
now the first and most important thing
to report is that
a lot of the key guidance is already in
our policy
so we've not had to make any significant
and substantial changes
what we have done is go through and pick
out areas where we can make slight
improvements
in line with that guidance and those
specific changes in word are set out in
the appendix
uh what would happen now
is that we will once members have had
their inputs today we will take it
forward to a public consultation
and we then bring that consultation
feedback back to the committee in due
course
before it becomes recommended to council
for
uh full adoption chair
um i don't intend to go through all the
different changes that we've
set out in the tables in the appendix
i'm quite happy to answer any questions
that members have got
either about the process or about those
particular changes
thank you kevin uh does anybody have any
comments
or questions
nope uh no one's indicating chair
oh second counselor windley yeah sorry
i'd i'd switch my
mic off for a while um are we sort of
commenting
on all of these um or are you doing them
as a
one by one in the appendix
it was my intention to allow counsellors
to pretty much jump in and
start where they wish to in terms of
picking out any
uh comments you wish to make or any
changes to the wording that you think we
need to
make
okay yeah go
go ahead council sorry yeah mine was
just a query about some
safeguarding and disability awareness um
can i i ask
how often are these um updates
on this given to taxi drivers it's
it's just from my own you know i'm just
wondering how often
and they have to do these um courses
and do they have guidelines to follow
on how to place the wheelchair users
in their vehicles
yeah i mean answering that one i'd have
to check with the licensing officers
um certainly all existing drivers have
been through the training
and any new drivers that come on board
would be expected to go through it
uh as things stand i'm not aware that
we've got any renewal
programmes planned to be rolled out on
that awareness training
um what it does is it's
uh if i recall them correctly it's
effectively a dvd educating them on how
they ought to be handling
uh passengers
that fall under that category and the
uh there's no sort of um assessment
of sorts on that the uh
we do have um
there are separate issues around
wheelchair access deliberately built
wheelchair accessible vehicles
and there is a separate requirement that
anybody driving one of them should have
had appropriate training in loading
the wheelchairs into the vehicle
right thank you so so they they know
that there's a
correct way which is um frontal back and
not
sideways then and that kind of
thing and the different ways that they
can be shuttled down
that's all included in in the knowledge
and the training then that's given
to the drivers is it in terms of
vehicles that are
especially adapted for wheelchairs then
yes they would be expected to have
undergone training on making sure that
they can safely
uh load and unload passengers and secure
them for travel
right and what about the ramps are they
allowed to use
um two single ramps
to get a person or does it have to be a
block
uh rams please i've got to be honest i'd
have to find out i don't know the answer
to that question i don't know what the
the regulations require um
i'd have to ask yeah okay okay thank you
just running through my thoughts when i
was reading it thank you
oops michelle would you like to
yeah chair if i may assist there it
would depend
on the type of ramp which is um
part of the vehicle they can vary from
vehicle to vehicle so we don't have a
specific
ramp type but they do vary according to
the types of vehicles that they
are uh that their purpose built for or
have been adapted for
so hopefully that will um answer cancer
councillor wendell's question yeah
some drivers or in the past they used to
have a
a sort of a separate ramp not with the
drop down
tail and i have come across problems
where they
sort of come along with two separate
um ramps which is okay there's nobody in
the wheelchair
but i don't consider it safe practice if
someone sat in that wheelchair
that's that's just my personal view i
prefer the blocked ones because then
they're not running a risk of the
wheelchair going over
the side of one of the ramps so i i just
wondered
you know because i've lost touch a
little bit with um how they
have to operate so thank you
thank you can i just ask kevin on a
similar
vein um i just wonder if it would be
worth
adding the dementia friends training to
the driver's training
it doesn't take long um i don't know if
anybody else has done it i have
a couple of hours maximum um but it
might be an idea because i know the only
problems
i've ever come across in the village was
people ladies down the road
very upset because um her husband had
alzheimer's
and the driver was quite nasty with him
um
and you know i just i just thought that
might be an idea to add it on
because it's it it takes it's quite easy
it's a simple it's simple enough course
and it just points out
the difficulty people with dementia have
so it's a perfectly good suggestion
um i think it's something that we can
look at incorporating into the
you know there's a general requirement
that they take whatever training we
require of them
um so yeah what i can do separately to
this
is uh sit down and have a chat with uh
michelle and the licensing team and see
if that's something that we could add on
to
the uh training that the drivers are
expected to undertake
thank you i think it's a bit i think
it's a good idea i know there's a couple
of the written
lads who are trained to to to
to run the dementia friends training i
don't know whether we've got anybody in
the house but i know rick will have
that brings me to another question
uh again around training and
i was wondering if i know some some of
the taxes
who transport the young people
to and from schools or maybe colleges
and they can display um some behaviors
other drivers are actually expected to
have a
some kind of a training for managing
behavior
and obviously the escorts that go with
them
is that something that they actually do
as well that's not something that we
require of them that's a matter for them
and their arrangements with county
council
i'm sure i don't know what uh
level of training or
similar that the county might require
when they give their contracts out
right okay thank you because i know some
of the children that
they can sometimes display some
behaviors that can be difficult to uh
deal with
uh and i just wondered you know the
young people they're getting into the
taxes
um and sometimes it can all end up
with a bad um sort of result
if you like but thank you thank you
has anybody else got any comments to
make
counselor reader well go ahead council
reader thank you
and so yeah i think just to comment
really
that obviously we're being asked to kind
of look at this as a policy at the
moment so my sort of view is that
um you know taking into account the
wording and everything
and it has tightened up a lot of the
policy
um um you know um
even just down to the dbs checking and
things you know
it's it's acknowledging that we're
actually going to be doing more dbs
checking than there's actual a
requirement that's needed
and so that you know that that for me
tightens everything up quite nicely um
and as kevin said at the very beginning
you know there's not really a great deal
that we weren't doing before
and it's just looking at the wording of
what as so in terms of the actual policy
itself
and you know the way that it's been
worded it's tightened up quite a lot
um you know so there's no confusion with
regards to
you know what is meant in it so for me i
feel the policy
really has been it's been tightened up
and it is covering quite a lot of what
it needs to
cover i don't know what everyone else
feels but i'm quite happy with how it's
written
as well are we all in favor of it going
to public consultation then
can we can we vote on that yeah
i think that's everybody isn't it i
think that's agreed by acclimation chair
thank you alan thank you is that okay
with you kevin
absolutely chair um i'm really pleased
with the feedback that you've given
thank you and we'll take you forward as
drafted to public consultation
and bringing it back to you and your
course right thank you now matters of
urgency
now i have got something i don't know
how urgent it is but uh
i've been approached by um
the lads at the uh eckington depot
um they are being asked by the owners of
the
exemption vehicles the limousines etc
if they could possibly go back to an old
policy of having
a badge in the side window because they
said at the moment
the long badge that they used to have is
now fastened into the boot apparently
and when they get into airports people
don't know
that they are legal um the powers that
be at the airport don't know that
they're legal and they're having to get
out and open the boot
to show the ticket and they also said
they're quite having difficulty
fixing them into the boots of vehicles
because all
vehicles are carpeted these days and
they wondered if they could go
back to what they used to have a sort of
a tax disc
sized um
sign that says who they are and where
they're from etc in the passenger window
okay kevin thank you yeah
obviously last time we did the policy in
full which was 2018 we did make a number
of changes
including how uh music
played or similar could be achieved with
various vehicles
um i can't say for certain at the moment
um what i can't recall why we changed it
what i can say is i think we can go away
we can have a look at that
and can report back at a future meeting
um
if we can find a way to accommodate what
they're requesting
all i'd ask is if you've got the request
and
if you could send me something in an
email so that i can then take it forward
and
investigate it yes i can i only i only
received this
phone call this morning so yeah i will i
will do
um right if nobody else has got any
other
any worries that they can come up with i
think we can call
call that finished thank you chair
all right thank you thank you
thank you
you